NICHOLAS JITKOFF: Good
afternoon, everybody.
Thank you for joining us
for all of these sessions.
This is the last of the
material design ones
and we've saved
the best for last.
Motion is a key part of
everything that we're doing
and it deeply integrates into
many of the other disciplines
that we're thinking about.
I'm Nicholas, and I'm here with
a bunch of Motion designers
from across Google.
To start with, Ari
and I are going
to talk about some foundational
aspects of motion design
and then Helen,
Manuel, and Gus are
going to talk about actually
applying Motion designed
to different form
factors we've got.
It's only recently that motion
has become deeply considered
in user interfaces, despite
a long history of the media.
In film, movement has always
been used for storytelling.
NUIs that appear in
films will reflect this.
They support overall story
arc but often lack substance.
Video games have
a similar problem,
in that they have these
very immersive stylized UIs,
but they're very specialized
to a specific kind of task.
Traditionally UIs
are more versatile
and we see motion
applied there, but it's
often like a superficial
layer applied very late
in the process.
So when we were thinking about
all this we asked ourselves,
how can we use motion
to truly improve UX.
In the session
yesterday, we talked
about using motion
to provide meaning.
Particularly,
taking user actions
and connecting them with
the events that follow.
And this is sort of
the nature of stories
that show up in our UIs.
Every app and
feature and action,
tell a fragment of a story that
propagate throughout the day,
and explain everything
that has happened.
Interaction design is
also informed by motion.
In this album
example you can see,
this sliding up and down of
the album and the ability
to pull on it, affords
the pull gestures
that can show or dismiss it.
For this reason, we would
like to try to consider motion
as we're trying to do the
interaction design to say, how
can motion be used
to indicate what
is possible in these
places and refine it down
so it doesn't have
to be as complicated.
There's one other
variable we like
to consider when we
do this-- the user.
In all of our stories,
the user is the driver.
For that reason we base
as many transitions
as we can on the user's
touch, giving custom responses
to every single gesture.
This is why we liked the
notion of an advanced material
as the thing that we
build all UIs out of.
The touch ripples and the
magnetic attraction of it
to your finger
reinforce the fact
that the user is
causing these changes.
We want to feel like you're
the one giving life to the UI.
This isn't really only
to a single control
but actually, to transitions
happen elsewhere.
In this slowed-down
version, you can
see that the touch can
affect other controls
on the screen in a cascade
of different delays, that
makes it feel like they're all
tied to that original event.
And the purpose of this is
actually simplification.
By hiding things inside
of this energy wave,
you actually can have a lot
more detail in something
that feels very simple and
has a very clear cause.
This combination of
meaningful motion and user
initiated change are two
core principles in our work.
And they represent
a continual dialogue
between the user and
the system, and a wave
of teaching and training.
It's really hard
to get this right.
We really want the
essence of realism,
but without all
the extra baggage
that's associated with it.
Ari's going to go into
a little bit more detail
about how we accomplished
this taking elements
of traditional animation
and building upon them.
ARI SACHTER-ZELTZER: So Nicholas
talked about telling stories
and the dialogue between
the system the user.
There are really
three main areas
that drive the motion
language for material design.
The first is familiarity.
So we all live in the physical
world and our grounded
in reality, for the most part,
and motion is, in our UI,
is really key to support
that material metaphor
and bring that familiarity
to our user experiences.
So our environment is a shared
stage and all of the action
takes place there.
They're visually
consistent shadows,
across platforms, that
provide a visual indicator
of the layering, as well as the
separation, between surfaces.
And this environment is
proportional and bound
to the device that you have.
So for example, the
thickness of your phone.
And to that end, we
want to make sure
that we avoid extreme
motions like camera
zooms or large rotations
that break that environment
and take us out
of the experience.
We also represent
surfaces as solid object
that can be directly
manipulated.
So we use motion to express
material special properties.
Can split apart or join
back together without tape
and dynamically
transform and re-scale.
We can also use
changes in opacity
when transitioning to,
or from, high speeds
to imply motion blur, and
avoid fading in or out
in static states, to maintain
the feeling that the paper is
solid.
We also really want to use
motion as an affordance,
and express the transfer
of energy from the user
into the system,
and use this motion
to tell the story of how that
input propagates and results
across the system.
Whether there are
hard constraints
or forgiving
boundaries, all of these
are familiar
indicators that help
us understand how objects
can be manipulated.
Motion should also be
responsive and fast.
There's no need to bounce,
because the material is precise
and arrives precisely and
smoothly at the target.
We have a set of
animation curves,
that you've seen
across many examples,
and those are incorporated
directly into the framework.
And you can also
customize those curves
with the new path
interpolator and Android L.
Choreography is how
we guide our users
through the experience with
thoughtful and consistent
motion.
When transitioning between
spaces or activities,
we want to use
motion to complement
the spatial model of
your app, and consider
motion in the articulation
of these surfaces
in the first place,
when designing
how your app is put
together in space.
Beyond the acceleration
and deceleration of objects
we, can also express
character by the path
that objects move along and
moving using curved paths.
Natural motion tends
to follow an arc.
For example, throwing a
baseball through the air,
or the path of a skier
down the mountain.
We can apply these ideas
into our transitions,
to make them feel less
mechanical than when they are
constrained along
a straight path.
And here you can
see this dynamic arc
and create fun paths to or from
any position on the screen.
And you can do similar
things in Android L
by now, supplying a path
into the Object Animator.
So in addition to the path
objects take and the character
of their acceleration,
thoughtful timing of actions
is critical to building
meaningful transitions.
We want to sequence actions
to guide user's attention
around the screen or draw their
attention to promoted actions,
build understanding of the
changes that are occurring,
and indicate individuality
or grouping of elements
through synchronize motion.
And in addition to
familiar surfaces
and coordinated
motion, craftsmanship
is really the manner in which
all these principles come
together to create a really
compelling experience.
Attention to detail and
a well considered motion
at all scales, can bring delight
and clarity to your users.
So at the largest
scales, we want
to create transitions
that connect the users
action to the resulting change.
Motion can bring clarity
to the changes in context
and improve the understanding
of the relationship
between different spaces.
And animation at smaller
scales can tell a story
when space is limited.
For example these
micro transitions
can give cues about
the changes in state
or reinforce functionality
through motion or drive
discoverability.
And these principles around
familiarity, choreography,
and craftsmanship
have really been
the foundation of
a lot of the design
work we've been doing recently.
And now Helen,
Manuel, and Gus are
going to talk a little
bit more about how
we've put these to practice
in desktop, handsets,
and wearables.
HELENE PARK: I'll be
diving into detail
about the ways we've been
exploring the loading
experience, and ways that
alleviate the wait time.
So loading, and often
overlooked, but an extremely
common occurrence,
is an opportunity
for consistent control
across different contexts.
We started off by combining
a refresh icon and a loading
spinner, for a seamless
and simple correlation.
Spinner is the original activity
indicator, crafted in detail,
with an organic pattern.
Playing with how dynamic colors
can compliment the whole system
and framework, and in
this scrolling instance,
the spinner is paired with
an ink splash, inspired
by the touch ripple effect
to indicate an initiation.
Our suite of progress
and activity indicators,
circular or linear, are designed
with a synchronized cadence.
Whether it's a swipe down to
refresh on mobile, or opening
a message on tablet,
acceleration curves
and rotational rhythm
are choreographed
to follow the same,
organic pattern.
We've also thought
about how these
can be tailored to
a variety of uses.
In this Chrome OS
update instance,
we thought about how the
indicators can behave
like bookends, for
distinct, beginning and end.
A field of color marks an
initiation and an equally
dramatic ink splash punctuates
a marker of completion.
On top of all this, we thought
about how an image would load,
and we were inspired
by the way photographs
are exposed onto paper and
developed in a dark room,
for a natural and
familiar process.
We've broken it down to
three basic phases; capacity,
exposure, and saturation.
The image would fade in at a
low-contrast exposure, followed
by a full color saturation.
Form factors with
larger surface areas
are the ideal
places to pronounce
this type of a new treatment,
such as logging into Chrome OS.
MANUEL CLEMENT: Thank you.
Hello.
So Helene showed you
a Chrome OS example
and I'm going to talk
to you about some
of the ways we use motion
on Chrome, across desktop
and mobile.
OK so in the case of a
desktop or laptop OS,
we're dealing with many
windows and screens
and depth is key to ensuring
users feel in control
of their experience, as they
change applications and manage
their experience.
So here, we're using
material shadows
to communicate quite
a bit of depth there.
Now see what's happening?
The UI is actually
now being scaled up,
even though it looks like
it's coming closer to you.
Simply by using the right curves
and the appropriate durations,
and the right
properties that shadow,
you create this nice,
crafted, smooth transition.
We've all seen
shadows like this.
The fact that it's nicely
transitioning like this
creates a great continuity
between those states.
Moving on, this is Chrome OS.
You guys know Chrome
OS, Chromebooks.
In Chrome OS we
have an app launcher
and this App Launcher
has this feature now,
that allows you to
group applications.
And Android, you
can do that too.
Now on Chrome OS,
the app launcher's
already a floating box.
OK, a folder usually opens
up as a pop-up box as well.
We don't want do that.
We don't want to put a floating
box on top of a floating box.
So in this case we're using
material Ink and material
Response, where Ink is
shrinking and growing,
and creating this nice ink
bubble metaphor for a folder.
And so you see the same bubble
appearing, disappearing,
and throughout the
different states
that you are going
through as a user.
It creates this
familiar thing there.
It's really nice.
Next, let's take a look at a
Chrome-for-mobile prototype.
Here, when you're looking at
finding a way to transition
and from very different
states-- see this right here?
That's a very different
state from this one.
All these icons are there,
and not there anymore,
and if you just flip a bit
and you could hide show.
It's not going to
look very good.
In this case, imagine the
person's touching the screen.
Boom.
A circle of energy
flies out of there
and pushes items,
[MAKES SWISHING NOISE] out
of the way, back into the scene.
It feels like you're creating
a story for the user,
through choreography and motion.
Finally, let's look at
the Chrome OS again.
Large screens present
quite a bit of challenge.
You've seen a lot of examples
of smaller mobile screens.
Now making something
fly up and down
that screen may not
be a huge issue.
Imagine you're looking
at screen that's
much bigger, like 20
inch, for example,
or 17 inch, even
a 13 inch laptop.
You want to avoid forcing your
users to scan around like,
is my window coming to the
left, to the right, to the left,
and it's just crazy.
So one way to do
this is exploration.
Looking at ways to go "whisp"--
like have very short animations
to show, hey the window just
went toward the Close button.
Or the window just flew from
the button on the task bar,
therefore it probably
opened the application.
Things like that.
So even though those
animations are really short,
because we're using the
right curves material
and we're very thoughtful
about the way things are moving
on the screen, you create
tangibility and familiarity
to animations, and communicate
those states really well.
Now, you've seen
really large screen now
and challenges and
solutions we're exploring.
Gus is going to show you
similar challenges and solutions
for tiny screens, like this.
GUS SONODA: Thank you, Manuel.
I just love motion design.
I think they are-- it's
a powerful design tool
and still it can be subtle.
And we use that a lot when
designing for wearables.
So because of it's
small screen, we
don't have space
for multiple panels
or different buttons
for every action
that we can take
in every screen.
And nor do we have
space for white space.
So in order to fully
express the material design
language on such
a small screen, we
needed to use a lot
of motion design,
to cover for all those functions
and also to make the device fun
and easy to use.
So right from the
start, even before you
start interacting
with the device,
we have added a simple animation
that explains the structure
navigation of the
wearable device.
It's a pretty simple one.
You scroll up and
down to navigate
through different
pieces of content
and you swipe right
to dismiss a content.
So even though
it's pretty simple,
it's just enough
to get you started,
so you feel comfortable
using the device.
As you start using the device
and you face situations
we have never
encountered before,
motion design is
there to suggest
how to interact with it.
So in this case,
incoming call, you
swipe one side to accept
the call, or the other side
to reject a call.
We then end up with a very
simple stream of cards,
where we show one
content at a time.
And so we quickly
realized that it
was very important to
work on the transitions
between those contents.
So we orchestrated
all elements present
on both screens
and, for example,
the acceleration of the
card, the cross-fade
of the background, and
the parallax movement,
in order to make these
transitions feel smooth.
And actually, we want
it to feel invisible
because you're going to
interact with it a lot of times.
We have also brought
animations that we
are used to in order
devices, to wearables.
Not before making some
tweaks and improvements.
Let's take, for example,
the nod animation.
So nodding is something
that we do everyday
when interacting
with other people.
When we are talking
to them, we just
nod to acknowledge
their presence,
to give non-verbal feedback.
And it help to create a friendly
environment for a conversation
to take place.
So we wanted to take
this environment
and bring it to our UI.
And we use that with the nod,
using a very simple motion
design.
We have also created a
full set of animations.
That they all cover a very
specific function in the UI,
but we have crafted those
animations in such detail,
in order to make every micro
interaction feel rewarding.
So lets take the sending
a message, for example.
So you have just sent a
message using our new wearable,
using our voice, without
even touch your phone.
So that's a pretty amazing task
you have just accomplished.
So we wanted the confirmation
animation for this task
to be as awesome as a
task you have just done.
So we crafted every animation
with a lot of detail.
And the boot sequence.
So we have done
at a boot sequence
that, when you start looking
at it, as soon as you turn
the device on, and you see
running at this high frame
rate, in such a small
device, it immediately
suggests how powerful
the device is.
And it sets the
tone of how you're
going to interact with
it, from that moment on.
Nicholas.
NICHOLAS JITKOFF: So
these guys gave you
a good idea of a lot of
different applications
of motion.
And in each is tailored to
the specific form factor.
I wanted to go into a
couple opportunities
that we saw while
doing all this work.
First, use motion to tell
your product's story.
As Gus showed in that--
sending an email confirmation.
It was a moment for
a lot of personality
and it had a celebration for
an action that was, itself,
pretty impressive.
We want you to find moments
to make your apps truly shine
and focus on those.
Beyond that, use the frameworks.
The elements will cover
many, many of the use cases
are going to have
with animation,
with a standard
set of behaviors.
You want to build
on those, but then
also pick moments to enhance.
So using things like, the
shared element transitions,
which allow you to
persist and element
from a state to state,
or even between apps.
Or refining an
existing component
using theming or just
building upon it,
is a much better approach
to doing this stuff.
Where you are spending your time
on the most impactful portions
of your app.
And last, make motion part of
the process from the beginning.
There's so much stuff
that has emerged
from us working between motion
and visual, motion interaction,
and seeing how those disciplines
can build off of each other
and enhance each other.
It's really critical to
get a polished result.
Many of you have probably
already looked at the spec.
The motion portion of
the spec is probably
the richest and
most complicated.
It's definitely
worth looking at.
Ari and the others have
put a lot of thought
into the underlying physics
and behavior these materials,
and there's a lot
of detail in there.
Also, please visit our design
site and also get in touch with
us at the +Google design page.
This has been a really
exciting project for us
and we've been really
excited to share it with you,
but really this
is the first step.
And we have a lot of distance
to go before this is finalized
and we really want to see how
it applies to all of your apps.
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
So we're happy to take QA now.
We'll also be up here
afterwards if you
want to come chat with us.
AUDIENCE: I had just a
really brief question.
You're little refresh icon
spinner thing was awesome
and is there any
way we can have it?
Is that just something you
guys designed for this stuff,
or is it somewhere in
Android, hiding in a folder?
NICHOLAS JITKOFF: That is t
the standard Android progress
indicator.
So it should pick up theming
like any other element.
AUDIENCE: Sweet.
I hadn't seen the
arrow part on it.
NICHOLAS JITKOFF:
The arrow transition
is a customization of it.
I'm not familiar
with how we actually
go about doing
those things, but--
AUDIENCE: All right, well,
it's sweet, so thank you.
NICHOLAS JITKOFF: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
We've seen all those animations
and they look really amazing.
When I look at that
and try to think
how I'll do that with
the current Android API,
I feel like shooting myself.
[LAUGHTER] I've seen some of the
presentations for the new APIs
that are coming out and I
assume that all that animation
is going to be much easier
to do now with the new APIs?
ARI SACHTER-ZELTZER: Yes.
Yeah, we're making a lot of
progress in that direction.
So for example, moving things
along curve paths, the Object
Animator-- I'm a designer so I
may not get it totally right--
but the Object Animator
can accept a path,
so you can animate x
and y concurrently,
create a-- on a spine path, as
well as the path interpolator.
So you can apply to customized
acceleration, deceleration
curves with cubic-bezier--
pretty much the same format
as you would with CSS.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
In the beginning
if your talk, you
showed how elements don't need
to bounce because they just
arrived at the destination
perfectly on time,
but in the internet
wear, you showed
how the red circle G, kind
of bounced down then out,
like in it's nod animation.
So how do you balance
those different animations
and when to use them or not?
GUS SONODA: OK.
So I think the
bounce animation is
this, is a different,
and specific animation
to make you the user feel the
visual feedback for the user
input.
So for all other
animations, we do not
encourage a bounce animation.
I would not count the nod
animation as a bouncing
animation, it's
simply a movement,
a natural human movement that
we incorporated into the UI
as a feedback.
AUDIENCE: Got you.
Thanks
ARI SACHTER-ZELTZER:
I'll just add
onto that, that for a lot of the
transitions that we're doing,
we're really
perceptive to motion.
So having secondary motion
or really bouncy stuff,
sometimes can draw your
attention to things
that you don't really
want people to look at.
ARI SACHTER-ZELTZER: This is
a personal obsession of mine,
so I'm going to go into
a little bit more detail.
We like to think of this
technologically advanced
material as something that
is driven by the system.
And system understands physics.
It can understand how
to place something
exactly where it
needs to be, and not
wobble as it gets there.
But the same time, it needs to
be very responsive to the user.
So if the user is
pulling something
passed the bounds where it
needs to be, to just simply stop
would be almost hostile.
We want it to
accommodate the user,
but in the times that
it's moving things,
to also land them perfectly.
So it's balancing the
two of those things
to get the right feel, as well
as the right amount of, sort
of, forgiveness, when
you pull past bounds.
AUDIENCE: I'm a UX designer.
When I saw your motion
design talk on the schedule,
I was so happy.
Not many conferences have
a motion design talk,
so I'm so glad you had it.
So I have two questions.
One question is, what tools do
you use for prototyping motion?
The second question is,
your decks are amazing.
And I'm curious to
know what tools you
are using for presentations.
ARI SACHTER-ZELTZER: I think
well-- a lot of our motion
designers use After Effects
for just some initial studies,
but of course that
can only get so far
when so much of this motion
is tied to the interaction
and how it feels.
So there's kind of
that diminishing return
as you go past a point
to get an idea of,
OK this is a direction
that feels good.
And then we really try and
start working with engineers
and prototyping to kind of
start seeing it on a device
and feeling it, to
know if that's actually
a right decision.
MANUEL CLEMENT: I'll jump in
and just-- can you hear me?
I'm going to add one point.
All the examples I showed--
I'm really a designer,
but I like to code
things to try them out.
I love to kind of
push the browser,
see how fast it
can render stuff.
In any case, most
the stuff I showed
were actually video, QuickTime,
like, screen recordings
off interactive prototypes I
built, using just HTML stuff.
Also, Polymer, I really
enjoy doing that.
So like the window
control that's
coming in now, that was a custom
element in Polymer I built.
But, yeah, HTML I found
great, because then
when you communicate these
animations to engineers,
they can look to code
or you could just
copy paste your variables,
and they're like, oh yeah,
that's the curve.
It talks to them really well.
But different designers
work differently.
[INAUDIBLE] effects
tool is really
awesome for doing a
lot of things too.
NICHOLAS JITKOFF: Even
basic blocking emotion,
I think is very effective.
Particularly if people are
using the standard curves.
As long as they're explaining
how things move from state
to state, it's more than
enough to understand.
It's just, think
about state to state,
rather than just assume that
it's gotten there on it's own.
ARI SACHTER-ZELTZER: I'd also
add that motion design has
been a really interesting point
in the process of developing
the system and apps,
where it really
forces UX designers to work
with engineers to kind of get
these ideas and make sure
that those kind of concepts
are carried over into
the final product.
So it's a great opportunity
to increase collaboration
and also helps to build some
understanding on each side.
So as a designer I'm starting
to learn more about XML.
So that way I can tweak
stuff myself and make sure
I pass along the right
kind of information.
Also, take the right
kind of considerations
when I'm making designs.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
You guys mentioned
using the frameworks.
And so my question
is, if we're trying
to design an app that works
in HTML and on Android,
and trying to make
the look and feel be,
obviously as close as we
can, say, loading an image
or progress, like you guys
do examples you guys used.
How much the framework is there?
Are you guys focusing on
trying to put the same look
and feel for motion into
these different frameworks?
Or are we will at the
stage of, sort of,
wire framing it in and handing
something overture HTML
guy and our Java guy and
saying, figure this out.
Or are you guys-- are the
frameworks working on giving us
more common tools between this,
so that our image loading looks
exactly the same between an
Android app and an HTML app.
NICHOLAS JITKOFF: We
are doing our best
to coordinate the
appearance and the behaviors
across the platforms to be
highly consistent, if not
identical.
Things like standard controls,
stuff like the ripples
that you see on stuff, or on
elements, of the tap them.
We've been very concerned
with making sure
that the same formula, or logic,
is used, for the way they move,
so that they are as
close as possible.
AUDIENCE: And we're talking
about Polymer framework here?
NICHOLAS JITKOFF:
Apps and Polymer.
AUDIENCE: OK.
All right, great.
Thanks.
AUDIENCE: So you guys talked
about the continuous motion
and things not stopping
immediately and things
like that.
Have you taken a look or
has it changed anything
in Androids list
view, for example,
when you reach the top?
It's always just stopped.
Is that something that
you're looking at changing?
Or how do you look at that
from a motion perspective?
NICHOLAS JITKOFF:
We're continuing later
on that class of animation.
We're looking at
how refreshing works
and how the ends of controls
work with loading more content.
That's something
that we're still
working on for the
final L. Trying
to get that all nailed down.
AUDIENCE: Cool, thanks.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
My questions is
about the process.
I'm just curious,
what kind of decisions
do you have to make while
finalizing the design?
And how difficult it is that?
What are the possibilities
you're looking at?
And how do you finally narrow
down the details of the motion
that you're creating?
ARI SACHTER-ZELTZER:
Well, I think
I can answer part of that.
But Nicholas talked a bit
about how motion design, really
trying to promote
that, is appear
to visual and interaction
design and really integrate that
throughout the whole
development process.
And I'm sure you've
found, many of us
have been in
situations where you
go from-- you get
some wire frames
or you get some visual
designs, and these things
have been done in sort
of a sequential process.
And then you say, OK, we
need to make a transition
from the state of the state.
And you're like, well,
that might not actually
work because this certain
transition, or kind of motion
wasn't really
considered at the point.
So you kind of get a
bit of churn there.
So that's why we're really
trying to make sure that when
you're thinking
about interaction--
and it really helps with
the whole material metaphor,
because sometimes you can
actually just take some paper
and think about, how would
these surfaces actually
articulate against each other?
And how I get from
one place to another?
Very, very lo-fi
prototyping ways.
So trying to just
make sure that you're
thinking about the motion.
If that's part of the
transition or part of your app,
throughout the whole process.
NICHOLAS JITKOFF: And engaging
with engineering, early, too.
That's one of the
things we realized.
You need to sanity check
many of these things.
These guys make some
crazy aspirational stuff
that-- motion blurs
and other things
that are just not feasible.
So just getting a sense of
what is actually possible,
and then refining
those animations
within the bounds
of what is possible.
GUS SONODA: Regarding the
part of your question of how
she selected the best
motion, sometimes
we make different versions
of every animation.
And you might think
a lot about it,
but once you it--
usually on the device--
it just it just
starts to feel right.
And there's a lot of
decisions that you simply
feel that it is the correct
and more fluid and faster
way to make a transition.
AUDIENCE: So a lot of
testing involved I guess.
MANUEL CLEMENT: If you have user
testing going on on your team,
everybody can look at
that and their numbers.
And see how it improves
as you reiterate stuff.
But I like the point
of starting early.
It's very important.
The Chrome stuff
I was showing you.
Visual layout, everybody was
talking together on the team.
And very early on, stuff
started moving around
and it-- oh this is too
much, this is too little--
and we got a chance to
look at it earl early on.
And just reiterating a lot.
The communication flow between
the different people on the UX
team, as well as engineering,
is super important.
So they feel included too.
You don't dump
something on their lap
that's super outrageous.
It may be the right
design but, you know--
And that's more like team
dynamic type strategy stuff.
Not really UX.
ARI SACHTER-ZELTZER:
And also, when
Gus was talking about the nod,
and even in the visual design
talk, about thinking about the
brand and your color story.
Think about that
the character, maybe
the personality of your app.
And if you kind of
understand that app
as a person or
personality, then that's
a really good bar to
keep your motion tied to.
So if it's fun or familiar or
serious or quick or sort of--
whatever it might be--
that something to help
keep it consistent across.
AUDIENCE: OK.
So there is some logic to it,
the way you come to decisions.
AUDIENCE: Hello.
Do you show examples
of this material design
may apply to phones,
watch, laptops?
Have you also considered auto
and what could potentially
be different they,
given the fact
that they used to just
glance the screen of the car,
and could potentially miss
some of the animations.
Or maybe it's actually
better to highlight
what are the most
important actions.
Have you given any sort to auto?
NICHOLAS JITKOFF: I don't think
any of us have worked on a car.
ARI SACHTER-ZELTZER: No, I
think, well-- No, none of us
have worked directly
on the auto stuff
but I think what we're trying
to express with the principles,
is that there's a real
range of possibilities.
And really understanding
your target audience.
Just like, the personality,
for example, on a car,
you don't want to have
lots of motion that
could be distracting.
You want things to
be really concise.
Same way on the wearable,
where you don't maybe, have
a lot of real estate, motion
is really an affordance
to indicate what
options there are.
How to manipulate the interface.
So there's-- Sorry, go ahead.
NICHOLAS JITKOFF:
These are very focused
on active, attentive interfaces.
I think on car, the
tools you'll see used
are going to be more focused
on using change blindness
to actually have animations
that deliberately hide change,
so people's attention
isn't drawn.
Or are rarely are used
to explain hierarchy
when you actually are engaged.
But there's a whole
separate set of things
that are probably
worth throwing talk.
MANUEL CLEMENT: You've seen
back there the projections that,
all these motion of the
UI for the hundred auto.
It's pretty neat stuff.
Maybe can talk to people there.
They would answer questions.
The one thing I would say,
having worked on car stuff
before, is not only there's
a problem of not distracting
the user, which
is very important,
but also, the screens they use
in cars, the reason why they're
not as fancy as tablets,
is because there are really
rugged devices that are
there automotive grade.
And so they have to deal with
a lower frame rate, often,
and then the touch response
may be a little slower.
So there's a lot of
challenges there.
The animations have to be
designed a little differently.
Although, what they show there's
pretty cool on the big screen.
Go talk to them.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
When it comes to actually,
practically implementing
a lot of these animations, how
well-- two questions, one is,
how do they gracefully
degrade down
to something like a
Gingerbread device?
And then, how
backwards-compatible
are they with something down as
far as like, ICS or something?
ARI SACHTER-ZELTZER: I
don't-- I wish we had one
of our engineers to talk
about really about the full
backward-compatibility story,
but I think there's a lot
of new API is in L. Specifically
to enable this kind of stuff.
For example, the native
shadows and the object animator
with pass and the
path interpalator
I think there's a similar
story to the visual design.
If you design for the high
end it's easy to pare back
and start thinking about, what
elements of this transition can
we degrade for
devices that don't
have had some of those features.
NICHOLAS JITKOFF: I think
one other important point
is too, be conscious of
the things that are only
indicated or afforded by motion.
It's often better to have
additional affordances
We generally couple the
dimensionality with motion
to indicate that this
thing is movable.
Allow it to be capable
of falling back
on something that's a
little bit more static.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
AUDIENCE: I'm going to ask a
somewhat antagonistic question,
just for the sake of discussion.
In the last-- I don't
know-- since the 1970s,
people have been talking about
escaping the metaphor of paper
on the internet.
And using more dynamically
generated content.
And not being limited
by the real world.
What are the weaknesses
of the paper metaphor?
of material design
as people are trying to
push other ideas forward?
NICHOLAS JITKOFF: I think the
things that we have run into,
is when we over-apply elements.
I think one examples
from visual design,
was when everything's on a card.
It's too easy to fall
into the trap of,
want a great deal of contrast
between different elements.
This is also true of motion.
It's pretty easy to
try to animate things
that aren't for the right thing.
The key drivers of
emotion we've been doing,
was deciding how you're going
to manage the user attention.
You want to move things in such
a way that your eye catches
the last or the first thing,
but very deliberately chosen.
And that we avoid having
things moving counter to that
or creating disturbances.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
NICHOLAS JITKOFF: She
asked about how the system
itself might hold
back other ideas.
I'm trying to think.
Generally we've
been trying to be
so flexible about the amount
of theming and structure
in the stuff that it is actually
looser than any other systems.
Even though there's a
lot of baseline elements
you could use.
Let me think.
The thing is that,
generally when
you run into a problem
with the system,
these are intended
to be guidelines.
They're not intended to be
end-all-be-alls of what it
should be.
They're starting points.
And part of what
we're trying to do
with Polymer and with Android,
is establish a baseline level
of quality that you start
with and then can build upon.
And as we see people
applying the brands to apps,
or just sort of
building them out,
we want, and encourage them
to take this, and build on it,
and make something a
little bit more extreme,
or tailored to whatever
their specific use cases is.
But this is sort
of, the baseline set
of elements you start with.
ARI SACHTER-ZELTZER:
And also, we've
tried to really be considered
in how broadly they
can be applied.
As you saw in the
keynote, there's
a lot of different
platforms being announced,
a lot of lot of
different form factors.
And each one of them
has their own nuances
for what kind of depth
and what kind of surfaces
that we want to represent.
So I think as we continue
to evolve those platforms,
I feel like we've set up a
system that has enough, kind
of, flexibility and dynamic
range that we can grow on it
and expand it to
accommodate those.
NICHOLAS JITKOFF:
I have something.
If the illusion gets
broken, it is a big problem.
And this could happen
in many, many ways.
Like dropped frames due to
like-- if an animation should
lose frames, or the
perception of this thing
as being realistic is violated,
that is one of the ways.
You recognize these
as failings in the UI.
That's why we're trying to
avoid things like jump cuts.
Or trying to focus on
very specific, tailored,
animations that aren't part
of a larger system that's
not totally resolved.
Having people's primal
understanding of dimensionality
and shape relies on it being
internally consistent and not
overbearing.
So trying to balance how much
to do and avoid the times when
it is too much,
or it falls down.
ARI SACHTER-ZELTZER:
And we'll hang around
if you want to chat some more.
NICHOLAS JITKOFF:
Any other questions?
We'll be up here if
have anything else.
It was good to see you all.
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]